[Music]
everybody loves fireworks the lights the
colors and of course the big boom but
the history of fireworks isn't all hugs
and celebrations long before epic
fireworks displays chemists in China
invented the key ingredient that propels
those bright lights into the sky that
invention was what we now call gunpowder
our story begins back in ancient China
in the mid 9-3 where early Chinese
alchemists were trying to create a
potion for immortality instead what they
created was a flammable powder that
burned down many of their homes they
quickly realized that this black powder
which they called fire medicine was
precisely the opposite of something that
would make you live forever in these
early days the Chinese hadn't yet
figured out how to make the powder
explode it was simply very flammable and
their armies used it to make flaming
arrows and even a flamethrower
but once they figured out the right
proportions of ingredients to create a
blast they began using the powder even
more creating fireworks to keep evil
spirits away and bombs to defend
themselves against Mongol invaders it
was these Mongols
most likely who spread the invention of
gunpowder across the world after
fielding Chinese attacks they learned
how to produce the powder themselves and
brought it with them on their conquests
in Persia and India William of rub rock
a European ambassador to the Mongols was
likely responsible for bringing
gunpowder back to Europe around 1254
from there engineers and military
inventors created all kinds of
destructive weapons from bombs to guns
to cannons
gunpowder left its mark on the world in
some pretty terrible ways in contrast to
the beautiful marks they can leave in
the air so how does black-powder propel
fireworks into the sky
you might have seen old westerns or
cartoons where a trail of gunpowder is
lit and it leads to a large and
obviously explosive barrel once the fire
gets to the barrel a large boom occurs
but why doesn't the trail itself explode
the reason is that burning the powder
releases energy and gases
while the trail is burning these are
easily released into the surrounding air
but when the Gunpowder is contained
within the barrel the energy and gases
cannot easily escape and build up until
boom firework canisters provide a single
upward-facing outlet to channel this
explosive energy the wick ignites the
Gunpowder and the energy takes the
easiest exit from the canister launching
the firework high into the sky the flame
then makes its way through the fireworks
encasing and the same reaction occurs
high above our heads so while the
Chinese alchemists never found the
compound for eternal life they did find
something that would go on to shape all
of civilization something that has
caused many tragic moments in human
history and yet still gives us hope when
we look up in celebration at the
colorful night sky
[Music]
you